[ Emerance Narrating ] You can look
just about anywhere from my house...
and you would see strictly land,
and that’s about it.
I live in Alberta, Canada.
My great-great-grandparents
came over here over a century ago...
and started a farm, and my dad
still farms the same farm today.
In Canada, there’s only two seasons.
One season is farming season.
The other is hockey season.
I have a brother, Bronson.
My sister is Brittaney.
I have a brother, Brock,
and a younger brother, Kache.
We all play hockey.
Since I was little, there was just one team.
I played with the guys.
After that, I continued playing guys’ hockey.
I wanted to challenge myself all the time...
and prove to everyone that I could be
just as good as the guys.
When I was 13 years old,
the team that I was playing on...
went to Boston for a tournament.
My mom and I went together,
and we toured Harvard.
I fell in love with it right away.
I told my mom,
“I’m gonna go here one day.”
My mom and dad taught us kids
to work really hard...
and always challenge ourselves.
They told us to have a good work ethic,
and no matter what...
no matter how hard it was,
to stick with it and you’ll get through it...
and eventually, you’ll have success.
My name is Emerance Maschmeyer...
and I play goalie
for the Harvard women’s ice hockey team.